por nada de concentración en Bogotá Como
cada por el presidente de Colombia
Gustavo Petro a sus partidarios para que
salgan a las calles para defender las
distintas reformas sociales que su
gobierno Busca cometer en los próximos
meses estas reformas son la de salud la
pensional y la laboral Y para esta joven
es pertinente este llamado del
presidente Gustavo Petro a las calles a
sus partidarios lo veo bastante esencial
y es importante que hagamos este este
llamado y convoquemos a la ciudadanía
para que precisamente se den cuenta las
personas que están en contra de esas
reformas pensadas para la población
vulnerable que hay un respaldo que hay
gente que gente que las necesitamos que
requerimos de estas reformas y que por
eso es que también Pues quedó Gustavo
Petro en la presidencia electo vimos por
ahí perdido pero más allá de estas
reformas sociales que ha convocado
Gustavo Petro a sus partidarios para
defenderlas en las calles también hay
interés en la población en La Paz total
llamada por el gobierno de Gustavo Petro
que acabar con décadas de conflicto y
negociar con estructuras armadas como el
ejército de liberación nacional el eln
la guerrilla activa más antigua de
América Latina con la que volvieron los
diálogos el pasado lunes en Ciudad de
México en un nuevo ciclo que busca un
cese al fuego esta esperanza en La Paz
nos Lamento
este partidario Gustavo Petro siempre he
pensado que que este país lo lo han
explotado demasiado
explotado demasiado y ahí como vemos
mucha gente está ya pues añorando una
tranquilidad una paz porque toda la vida
se ha vivido es una guerra yo llevo 70
años viviendo casi y de que desde que me
conozco siempre ha sido es mortandad por
todas partes
está bailando hay una pequeña
representación de la oposición
planteando las comunicaciones
se han adelantado un día ya que será
precisamente mañana
para la oposición para protestar contra
estas reformas sociales
y el miércoles para medir la temperatura
en las calles y predomina el apoyo o el
rechazo contra el gobierno de Gustavo
Petro y también una antesala a los
comicios municipales y departamentales
que tendrán lugar el próximo mes de
octubre